vous qui avez connu le le cinéma d'État
en URSS et puis les majeurs compagnie
aux États-Unis est-ce que le cinéma
d'Etat n'a pas du bon finalement la
différence que moi je le compagnie ici
une majorée de par votre film vous
pouvez aller à l'autre de la cinéma
d'État il y a quel temps voilà la
réponse bonne réponse
vous avez décidé de faire du cinéma
quand vous avez vu qu'on passe les
cigognes vous savez tout mais pourquoi
je suis ici
parce que la campêche les cigognes pour
nous effectivement enfin pour moi en
tous les cas ça a été je sais pas la
révélation du cinéma soviétique on
savait pas très bien quel était le
cinéma en URSS et puis on avait vu qu'on
passe les cigognes c'est vrai vous avez
raison c'est un film qui est vraiment
bouleverser complètement
quand j'ai décidé
j'ai fini j'ai pas fini les
consommateurs je dois la quitter parce
que je vais attach à cette époque et
j'étais pianiste j'ai été un an et mes
parents me préparer pour une carrière de
musicien et je ne t'ai pas du tout bien
parce que je pense que je vais pas du
tout le pantalon mais pas le patron mais
liberté de m'exprimer
alors je suis toujours j'ai essayé de
repousser de ne pas parce que je vais
pas vraiment
je veux pas
que ma mère sera déçue je pense que je
vais finir le temps après je serai le
cinéastes
votre passage à l'ouest comment à quel
moment vous avez tranquille ah bon
c'est jamais tranquille mais vous voyez
parce que j'étais marié avec une
Française et
pour moi c'était plus facile parce que
le soviétique ils sont mariés avec les
étrangers plus de droit de demander les
réseaux sociaux
alors mais vous voyez j'étais marié à
et j'ai quitté 1979 10 ans après je
travaillais beaucoup en Russie
et après je sais comment sentir que
c'est pas assez pour moi parce que pas
parce que j'étais pas j'étais malheureux
non
on peut très bien
moi j'étais assez satisfait par mes
films que j'étais là-bas comment tu vas
quelque chose que j'aime bien mais la
chose plus importante pour moi c'était
de voyager c'est terrible sentiment qui
soviétique à toujours c'est le sentiment
que tu dois rester dans un pays ou dans
un droit
de telle date à telle date et pas plus
terrible parce que c'est toujours le
groupe toujours comme de moutons autobus
hôtel autobus et partir
c'est horrible parce qu'on sait pas on
sait que jamais avoir cette ville à moi
parce que je dois partir consulter
pour moi le rêve était pas
ma fille Paris j'ai beaucoup plus de
racines ici ma grande Marie ma
grand-mère
était professeur de Sorbonne
50 ans
[Musique]
ici j'ai commencé je pensais que ce sera
plus facile pour ma canapé monsieur que
qui n'apporte parce que comme tous mes
films étaient assez bien
mais c'était pas facile c'est pas facile
j'ai écrit 4
comme balanski
moi non plus moi non et ce qui s'est
passé
chaque fois que j'ai créé le scénario ou
bien quelqu'un qui est cassait mes pieds
juste avant je sais pas pourquoi j'ai
l'impression par exemple Tascan
Duplantier parce que je suis un agent de
Quebec
parce que vraiment j'étais
presque seul soviétique qui habite à
et je peux vous dire que Maryse là
et je voulais le faire en France avec
Isabelle
alors tous mes projets étaient dans mon
bout dans la boîte je savais pas que ça
fait j'ai passé à peu près 3 ans en
chômage en Amérique essayez de prouver
que je préfère aussi là parce que ici
autant qu'ici j'étais
c'est bien connu en Amérique bien sûr
rien rien complètement alors
de se lancer comme ça non de venir en
France puis ça marche pas on va aux
États-Unis il faut y croire quand même
non
je manque de responsabilités
des chances de dispensibilité dans cette
sens j'ai voulu bien j'aimais bien
Amélie
j'ai pensé que ce serait plus facile
d'ailleurs
au moment que je commence à penser
peut-être je dois revenir
je pensais que tu souhaiterais trop tard
parce que je commence à voir l'horizon
les quelque chose dedans derrière les
gens quelque chose que je peux nager un
tout petit peu je vais aboutir quelque
chose et ce sera un peu plus c'est un
peu de 3 ans 3 mois après quand je
raconte l'installation
d'ailleurs j'ai je l'invité de vous
donner et j'ai eu 100 dollars c'est tout
Adoma c'est tout je vous jure
c'est un aventure je connais bien de
l'époque de parler parce que elle avait
fait mes films à Paris et nous avons vu
un projet de faire mouette d'ailleurs le
mouette en Londres on a discuté ce
projet et tout encore me demander il m'a
demandé si tu veux faire un film avec
moi et je suis
je crois pas je n'ai pas de projet un
projet j'ai fini l'histoire que je
pensais que tu peux le faire elle était
assez furieuse et je dis peut-être ça et
je vais compter l'histoire
malheureusement
si vous avez vraiment très bien parce
que cette époque à ce moment c'est le
Time Magazine est sorti avec le
couverture et des stars
américaine
alors dans trois semaines nous avons dû
un contrat j'ai commencé ce film donc
vive la chance quand même
oui bien sûr
c'est pas noté
après 11h je crois
mais vous qui avez connu le cinéma
d'État en URSS et puis les majeurs
compagnies aux États-Unis est-ce que le
cinéma d'Etat n'a pas du bon finalement
une majeure compagnie et pas votre film
vous pouvez aller à l'autre cinéma
d'État il y a quel état voilà la réponse
c'est bien bonne réponse à vous montez
la mouette ou à l'Odéon
mais comment vous comment vous avez
connu Juliette Binoche par exemple
comment vous avez connu son existence
vous l'avez vu au cinéma on vous en a
parlé
ah bon elle est venue elle-même elle m'a
dit
c'est pas après c'est pas avant c'est
notre chose
[Musique]
et
je les mets assez bien mais j'ai
vous voyez le rôle de Nina à moins
c'est un de plus difficile dur rôle de
répertoire mondial
très peu de rôles avec cette intensité
c'est pourquoi peut-être
accès souvent le spectacle n'est pas n'a
pas de force parce que c'est très
difficile
ça tombe verte
pas d'âge
c'est très difficile c'est très rare
alors je ne sais pas parce que nous
sommes disponiaux mais je vais vous dire
que Juliette
a passé une toiture
sur une fois pour l'actrice comme
Juliette de noces il faut pas mémoire
là-dessus elle vient elle dit il veut on
parle elle savait que vous vouliez
monter la mouette où elle vous savez
j'ai déjà fait en train de faire la
distribution
elle est venue une fois
je travaille avec deux heures elle a dit
je lui dis vous venez la semaine
prochaine pour une semaine prochaine je
voulais avec deux heures
elle est venue à peu près 8 ou 10 fois
pour
lire
pour lire sans savoir qu'elle va
travailler c'est dur
de force désir fort parce que le roman
se faire beaucoup et pour être sûr de ne
rien rater de tube abonnez-vous et
mettez un pouce bleu